le prototype du satellite scientifique
français ferrain est parti ce matin
d'orly à destination des états unis le
satellite doit en effet être lancés par
une fusée ce cas août le prototype a été
embarqué ce matin à bord d'un avion de
la compagnie air france pour traverser
l'atlantique et être essayés avec la
fusée américaine à la base de vandenberg
qui se trouve sur la côte du pacifique
le satellite fr 1 sera placé sur une
orbite polaire par une fusée ce cas où
tu
exactement semblable à celle que nous
voyons ici
est ferrain orbitera à 800 kilomètres
d'altitude
mais le lancement du satellite et
ferrand ne représente qu'une partie du
programme spatial français une autre
partie est constituée par le lan
satellite français diamant cette fusée
comporte trois étages premier étage
liquide deux étages supérieurs à poudre
jusqu'à présent ces trois étages ont été
essayées indépendamment les uns des
autres en vol est actuellement on
procède aux essais des deux premiers
étages ensemble qui constitue l'engin sa
fille lors d'un premier essai sapphire a
parfaitement fonctionné un deuxième
essai a été moins bon car le deuxième
étage topaz n'a pas exactement
fonctionné comme il fallait l'or au
cours de l'automne deux autres essais de
l'engin saphir vont avoir lieu et puis
ensuite la fusée diamant tout entière
sera mise à feu et dès le premier tir
diamant placera en orbite un petit
satellite a un que vous pouvez voir sur
cette photo la seule mission de cet
engin sera de vérifier que diamant a
bien fait son travail c'est à dire à
bien placer sa charge utile sur l'orbité
qui lui a été ordonné
si cette expérience est satisfaisante la
délégation ministérielle pour l'armement
qui a dirigé la construction de cette
fusée en remettra un exemplaire au
centre national d'études spatiales qui
s'en servira pour lancer le satellite d1
dont nous voyons ici une maquette d un
cdh essentiellement un banc d'essai
technique il servira au technicien
français pour savoir si leur matériel de
satellites est bon et fonctionne bien
vous remarquerez que des seins à des
cellules solaires qui transforment la
lumière en électricité alors à 1 n'en a
pas le programme initial prévoit que
diamant doit être lancé avant la fin de
cette année et si pour leur première
expérience spatiale les techniciens
français réussissent à tenir les délais
qui leur ont été impartis ce sera
vraiment une très belle réussite mais
nous sommes ici dans un domaine où la
technique peut réserver énormément de
surprises disons que l'homme propose que
la mécanique exposé espérons que la
mécanique sera bien disposés pour la
fusée diamant